madame la sénatrice laurence rossignol
sans même attendre d'avoir lu la tribune
dont j'ai évidemment pris connaissance
et je m'en suis entretenu avec marlène
schiappa dès hier suite à votre première
interpellation j'avais active et mes
services je vous confirme que j'ai des
remontées territoire à testeurs du fait
qu'il y à une réduction inquiétante du
recours à libérer pour les conditions
dans des conditions qui sont très bien
cité dans la tribune et pour lesquels
vous m'aviez déjà interpellé la dernière
fois je vous avais promis de regarder le
sujet parce que mon engagement est total
sur ce sujet et vous me donnez
l'occasion de vous de vous répondre sur
le fond
aujourd'hui d'abord vous dire très
clairement qu'il est hors de question
que l'épidémie de kobe 19 restreignent
le droit à l'avortement dans notre pays
plusieurs dispositions qui sont à
l'instruction et qui vont être prises
dans les plus brefs délais pour la
plupart d'entre elles d'abord rappelé
que pendant l'épidémie les ivg
médicamenteuses doivent être encouragés
facilité tout en garante en garantissant
un libre choix pour les femmes
j'ai demandé à mes services de
travailler sur une plus grande
utilisation de la téléconsultation que
la première consultation et que la
consultation de suivi après prise de la
pilule contraceptive puisse être faite
par télé consultation et non en
présentiel
restera alors la question de la
consultation au cours de laquelle est
délivrer la pilule abortive sur ces
questions là j'ai entendu la demande des
gynécologues de repousser le délai de
réalisation des ivg médicamenteuses en
ville et à domicile de sept à neuf
semaines
on est là sur des questions techniques à
savoir qu'il faut pas briser la chaîne
du froid parce que cette pilule se
conserve dans des conditions congelés et
donc nous sommes en train de regarder ce
qu'il est possible de faire sans prendre
de risques dans la chaîne du médicament
mais je le dis je n'ai pas de
d'opposition de principe avec cette
mesure vous dire que les
téléconsultations ont pris un essor
incroyable et que ça devrait permettre
aussi de répondre aux problématiques la
consultation avant et après j'ai demandé
à toutes les équipes des centres ivg
hospitalière de maintenir le recours à
l'ivg et instrumental enfin sur la
question des recours tardif
nous sommes en train de regarder il
existe une co
the de l'interruption médicale de
grossesse d'eau qui ne répond pas à la
question des délais pour des raisons de
détresse psychosocial et la question est
de savoir dans une décision collégiale
une fois que nous serons sortis du
confinement si effectivement on peut
considérer qu'une jeune femme qui
n'aurait pas pu aller en consultation
pour bénéficier d'un avortement dans les
conditions classiques de répondre à ces
conditions de détresse psychosocial vous
avions dit cela vous comprenez ma
position personnelle des réponses très
claires seront apportées à l'ensemble de
ces sujets en lien avec les gynécologues
avec ma collègue marlène schiappa je
remercie